- [Voiceover] A lot of
users of Khan Academy
especially teachers
don't fully know how much we have mapped
and how much we have invested
in the actual Common Core
and as I often point out to folks,
a standard is one thing
and the Common Core standards
are definitely more rigorous
than traditional standards,
much more focused on conceptual learning
but what really matters for a standard
is how it's implemented
and how it is assessed.
So over the last few years,
we've taken great effort
to create over a 150 thousand exercises
and many thousands of videos
that are directly aligned
to the Common Core,
explicitly created for the Common Core
and not only that
but they have been vetted
by the authors of the Common Core
and we've correlated them
with performance on Common Core exams.
So if you're a teacher,
a student or a parent
and want to explore
the Common Core resources we have,
I suggest that you go to
khanacademy.org/commoncore
or from there
and you can see that we
have some resources here
that describe what we have on Common Core
and how our materials
have even involved some of the people
who are assessing the Common Core
or some of the Illustrative Mathematics
is run by Bill McCallum
who's one of the authors
of the Common Core
on the math side.
But if you actually want to look at
what we have by standard,
you can click on Browse
our Common Core map
and you will go right over here
and you can see you can download it
as a kind of comma file or
CSV comma separated files
and that you can read on
Excel or on a spreadsheet
but you could also navigate it over here
and so you can see all of
the different grade levels
that are associated with the Common Core.
Once you get into high school,
it's much more by I
guess you can say class
or subject area
and if we pick a grade level,
let's say grade six
and you could see already here
that there's 107 skills
but each of those skills
has many questions involved
so there's 2678 questions
and you could click there
and you can see the different standards
and this is the actual description
of the Common Core standards
and then you can see visual pictures
of the different exercises
that we have for those standards
and so if you,
over here you see these
major themes in grade six,
geometry, ratios and
proportional relationships,
number system, expression and equations,
statistics and probability
and so you can click on any one of them
until you can see the types of things
that Khan Academy actually has
and you can click on any of these
to go to the exercises
and if you are a teacher,
this is actually a good way to explore,
hey, is this something
that might be appropriate
for my students?
You can then look at the URL up here
and then you can email it to your students
or send it on your
learning management system
or on a playlist of some kind
and then they can do it
and if you sign up as a coach
then you can track
whether the students have worked on it.
Also, you can assign it directly
through the Khan Academy
interface on missions
and there's other videos that
go into a lot of detail there.
And so you can see this exercise,
every student will get as
many exercises as they need.
If they don't know how to tackle it,
there are hints
which are essentially
step by step solutions
for that exercise
and every one of these
Common Core exercises,
these 150 thousand exercises,
we have videos that were
also explicitly created
for the Common Core associated with them.
So here, Writing
expressions word problems.
You can go into the library
and you can see the video
and this video in particular
does some example problems
from that Common Core exercise.
So you'll have some videos
that are more introductory.
We also have articles
aligned with the Common Core
that go deeper into it
and these could actually be printed out
and used as worksheets
or the students can use it directly
if they have access to
a computer or tablet
or even on a phone.
And of course, we have the actual,
we have the actual exercises here.
So in general, I encourage you,
let me go back to,
let me go back to the map.
Oh, it's actually right over here.
I encourage you to go back.
I encourage you to explore
our Common Core map on Khan Academy.
As you can see, it is very comprehensive
and as I said, it's done in conjunction
with some of the creators
of the actual Common Core
and above and beyond that,
if you're a teacher who's
teaching the Common Core,
there's a ton of other resources we have
on just even understanding
what the standards speak to
and how we can work together,
Khan Academy and you as a teacher,
to make sure that the students
have good mastery of it.
And all of that is actually encapsulated
as well in our missions
and the missions are really valuable.
You can use our library
and assign skill by skill
or video by video during the year
but in parallel to that,
our missions allow the
students to fill in their gaps,
work at their own pace
and usage of missions
correlates with out performance
on Common Core benchmark exams.
So encourage you to explore all of this.
We put a lot of work in this
and we'd love to hear your feedback
on how we can make it better.